こんにちははじめ社長です動画のタイトル
にもある
通り私はめ
社長しばらくの
間おやみしますお疲れ様でし
たえ今朝の4時か5時5時かな5時です朝
の5時ですおはようございますはいえ
ちょっとだけ動画をお休みさせてください
はいうんちょっと
[音楽]
ねちょっと忙しい忙しいというわけじゃ
ないですけどもなんかね忙しいというか
ちょっとちょっと疲れましたちょっと疲れ
ました何そういうやんだとか初めは闇落だ
とかそういうのじゃないんですけども
ちょっとだけねあのあのなんか最近忙しく
て本当にありがたいことに本当に
ありがたいことに忙しくてま色々お仕事
だったりと
かあとはみ社長のこのメインチャンネル
じゃない部分畑とかサブとかなんかこうな
んだろうで他にも会社のやんなきゃいけ
ないこととか色々ねなんか総合的に見て
忙しくなってこれちょっとメイン
チャンネル出すほどの余裕はないぞって
いうことでちょっとだけ動画をお休みさせ
てくださいなんかその物理的な忙しさも
あるですけどもなんかどっちかというと心
の余裕がないって感じですねなんか頭の
キャパがいっぱいみたいなもう
パッパラパー
ですバカになっちゃいそうバカになっ
ちゃいそうなんすよちょっとい忙し忙し
いって言い方が正しくわかんないんです
けどもなんか考えることがすごい多くて
最近俺考えることが多かったり悩んだり
するとねあの動画作りに支障が出るんです
よ
プロ意識が低いんでしょうねま良くも悪く
もプロ意識が低いんですよ
あのマジであの楽しいで動画撮ってる
タイプの人間なので楽しめなくなると動画
も撮れなくなっちゃうみたいなそういう
一面がちょっと僕ありまし
てちょっと考えるいやちょっとだけあのお
休みさせてください今ね動画を撮りながら
その色々考えるとかをなん
か話し合うとかそういうのがちょっとでき
なくてちょっと立ち止まって1回時間を
くださいあの考える時間にしますただこれ
はマイナスのお休みではないあの必ず
プラスになって帰ってきますので安心して
くださいなんなら今このなんか溜め込ん
でる悩みとかそういうのをあのしっかりと
解決してまたあのアホみたいなはみ社長で
動画撮りたいなと思ってちょっと悩み解決
期間とさせていただきます悩みというか
考え事だねどうしたものかみたいなあのお
休み期間中はもちろん動画は出ないんです
けどもあの撮影とかもちろんします
引き続きしてると思うのでちゃんとあの
復帰復活したらえ動画ちゃんと出るように
はすると思いますあとサブとか普通に出
ますだからなんかもうはめ社長姿くらます
とかそういうわけじゃなくて普通にSNS
とかにもいますしあの別
に大事なことなのでもう1回言いますけど
も病んでないですよ元気です元気だけど
片手間に動画撮りつつ解決できるような
ものじゃないような気がして
て一旦ちょっと時間をください
はいあのポロっと言うけどなんかねなん
だろう悩あの事務所とか関係ないですよ皆
さん覚えてますでしょうか僕去年ウム
やめるかもっていう爆弾発言をした動画
もし仮にもし仮に変わらずにあのメイン
チャンネルが取れないような状況が続く
ことがあればえ僕はおそらく迷いなくウム
をやめると思いますあの事務所が悪いとか
そういうのじゃないですはめ社長のこの
忙しいとか考える時っていろんな最近要因
があってそういうあの例えばその事務所と
何かあったとかそういう悩みとか動画外の
お仕事がなんか大変だなとかあとはやっぱ
あの社長なので社長ならではあの組織を
作っちゃってるのであの社長としての悩み
とかあとは実はね俺3チャンネル
レギュラーで出てるんですよはじめ社長
はめ社長2はめ社長畑でこの3チャンネル
とも全部ちゃんと動画出しまくってるんで
3チャンネル全部出て全部ちゃんと回し
てる人他にいるんかな俺以外にいないです
いたらごめんなさいそういうなんかもう
本当に物理的な忙しさとかああの恋恋わ
づらい恋ずらいは
えしばらく彼女作る気ないので大丈夫です
なんか本当いろんな悩みの要因があるので
一概にこれとは言えないんですけどもなん
か色々悩んでる色々悩んでて色々考える
時期に入ってる気がしててちょっと動画を
1回お休みさせていただいて考えつつも
けどあの動画はちゃんと取り続けていき
たいと思ってるので皆さん心配しないで
くださいなんかすごい嫌なことがあったと
か誰かに嫌なことがされたとかじゃなくて
本当1人でなんか抱え込んじゃっててあの
大丈夫でもはめはいつもみんなの画面の中
にいます心のそばにい
ますだから安心してくれ本当になんら問題
ないちょっとだけあの俺普段悩まないのよ
悩みのない人間なのでなんかたくさん悩み
がこうたくさんあるとちょっとびっくりし
ちゃうんでちょっとそこ
ちゃんとクリアしてちゃんと問題ないよう
にしてからえまたYouTubeの活動
頑張っていきたいと思いますなんかね活動
休止っていうとちょっとなんか大掛かりに
なりそうなのであの休止とは言わずに
ちょっとお休みしますと動画をちょっとお
休みさせていただきますとだけ言っておき
ますそんなね長く休むつもりはないよなん
色々準備が整えば復活しますのでそう時間
はかからないとは思いますごめんなさいね
最近ちょっと案件動画が続いたりとか
なんか勢いで撮ってる動画とか増えて感じ
たと思いますがちょっと忙しかった
です忙しくてなんか自分のしたいことでき
なくなったら俺結構うわあってなっちゃう
のでまだからここからはね本当に年末最後
ということでなんか自分の出したい動画を
出していけたらいいなと思って1回その
ためのこう羽休み期間いただきたいと思い
ますそしてえこのお休み期間が終わった際
にはですねまだ言っていませんはじめ社長
の今年の1年間何を禁止していたかも
ちょっと話したいと思いますそろそろ話し
ていい
でしょう何か分かった人いますかよかっ
たらコメント欄に書いてみてくださいはい
というわけでえまあ全元気にやっており
ますなんならえ明日はポケカの大会に行っ
てきます今俺がすべきことはもちろんやる
べきことはあるし動画も撮るし編集とかも
するけど
あの心を健やかに保つことだと思うのでで
あの1回精神状態をしっかりよくし
て考えてることを全部クリアにして変えて
いきたいと思い
ますお楽しみに
[音楽]
じゃん
DET